So it's going to be your task, to add
a task to send a confirmation email. The first thing
you need to do is add the sendConfirmationEmail servlet
to your project. And it goes in the servlet package.
You can get the servlet completely fully coded from
the Lesson 5 folder, or you can write it yourself
as you like. And then you need to make
sure you configure your send confirmation email servlet in web.xml.
Then you need to update the create conference function
in conference API. You need to add the functionality to
add the task, to the task queue when ever
anybody creates a conference. And if you like you can
also update this function to use transactions so that
the profile and the conference entities get saved together and
the task gets added to the Task queue, and that
all happens inside a transaction or none of it happens.
And you can get the template code, to add to
create conference from the lesson five folder, if you want or
you can try writing it yourself from scratch. So you can
optionally put the code, to create the conference inside a transaction.
When you add the task to the queue in createConference()
function, you can use the default queue or you can use
a named queue, it's up to you. But if you use
a named queue, you need to make sure to configure the
queue in queue.xml. You can also use the default
queue that configure it to use other options like change
the rate, or change the retry options. And again,
if you want to do that, you need to configure
it in queue.xml. In that case you would just
add a queue name default to queue.xml. So the development
server running on local hosts does not send emails, it
does add tasks to queues and actually has it's own
simple task queue viewer, but it won't actually send an email. So
if you to test the sending of emails you're going to need
to deploy your application to appspot. So when you've done testing it
on local host as much as you can, go ahead and deploy it
to app spot. And then to test it of course you're going
to need to create a new conference, and then check your e-mail
to make sure that the e-mail arrived. Did you get an e-mail?
And then go ahead and explore your test queues in the admin console.
So check off each of these steps as you do them